It's minecraft date the favorite kind of date, I love minecraft. No, I'm not addicted. Okay Sven
Oh god, no
Sven is lost again. Sorry guys another rescue mission necessary get away from him Spain
Get away from that dirty sheep. Come here
Teleport teleport Sven
Get away from him
No God. Oh God. Thank God
(Subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom)stay there stay stay there sick never spaek him again
You come near my dog again, if you so even go close to breathing in this distance. That's right
Don't look at me when I speak look at me when I speak to you. I mean, where's my where's my axe?
I would no, you know what even better. I will put this and I think you know where I will put it mr. Sheep (Subtitle by *I am HeRe *in description at bottom)
Mr. Walter. She you stay in this prisoner and you stay in this person forever Jeb. What kind of name is he?
All right, let's name him actually, yep this time because I want to see what this is all about
That's what this is all about. No way I pick up one thing. Oh, yeah. I have this ocean Explorer map, but
first
How do you do it? Okay, you put this here and then you type Jeb underscore and says yep on this score
Okay. All right. All right. What's shooting me? Who shoot at me?
Yeah
You're not water cow what did water cow go ah
Water cow. Oh
God
Water can we're all you which one is water cow, which one is water cat?
God I keep getting sidetracked. Also. I improved the IKEA Tower
It looks really nice. I like it. It's really nice from the distance - what else I changed flooring?
There's anyone care. Of course you do. Yeah, what Peter buy change flooring in Minecraft? That's awesome. Let's listen here. Yellow scoundrel
I don't like you. I'm giving this. Oh my god, that's awesome
Yay
He's changing
Why
Okay. All right. You know what? I'm not gonna lie. That was pretty epic
I'm not gonna you know, I'll give credit where credit is due
So I'm gonna feed you for the first time in base, but only to keep you alive
alright
Don't get any hopes. You're staying there forever. Oh gosh, wait, sorry
I got a I got a I got a do this. Well, this is get just give me one. Just give me one second
I'll I'll just got it. Okay, let's feed the these bastards. Not you which one is watertown, which one of you is wonder cow?
One cow lucky cow is going to become Porter cap. Oh, okay. You can become water follow me
Bobby gosh Walter cat would not give me this trouble. Come here. Hey
You have one destiny in this life and it's to become water cow with enough training
Get in just get it. Just get it. There you go, or you worry cap
I'm gonna train you every day. And one day you're gonna live up to become water count guys. Darn it. Okay, where was I?
Yes, yes. Yes, of course
My horse uragan. Okay. I'm not gonna lie. That's pretty I think
God there's so many distractions in this game. I never know what I'm doing seriously. Oh, yes. I have one quick thing
I really know you so if you take gunpowder and paper, which I've been farming from the paper
Farm that I have out there you see the paper form
You can make okay, so I'm a Minecraft veteran. So I remember fireworks
not neither freaky-deaky how
Since when did they add fireworks?
Alright. Yep, if that is your real name, look it he doesn't. Yeah, you better not look
whoa
Where's the explosion
Is that it?
Wow
That's so cool and yet again look at this
He loves and he loves it, where's Sven Sven look at this
Man, come here. Come here boy. Alright, look at this
He loves it alright Sven it's time for this epic gamer to hand out on epic adventure through the nether
Portal, how do I oh, yeah
later later
Gamer so last episode or a few episodes ago
I try to blow up these skies houses, right?
It didn't really work out
But I have another plane also
Apparently you can find a bunch of stuff in the nether like materials and like these blaze rods that are really important
I haven't seen anything. Where are they?
Help me. Help me gosh, darn it. We're like, we're hello
Looking all I see is pigs and the stupid nether. I hate pigs. They're not good not good like melon food-wise
anyone watch
Ok gamers here. We frickin go. Wait. It's just the wrong
Ah
Nether portal more like nothing in here portal hopefully pop booty pop booty snow pretty
Okay gamers three average later. Literally we are here
Okay. This is it. Oh
It's getting dark that's perfect
Joe tada, okay gamers. This is gonna be an epic gamer moment because we're gonna burn
It's all made of wood right
I wish I could bring Jerry into this because he would love to see this Jurgen loves to see other people's houses burned down
It's one of his favorite things
Okay, alright gamers
Sweden
Okay, okay, don't worry, don't worry don't worry gamers. Oh
God I made the bitch now, are they shoot themselves dummy dumb?
Okay, so, how do I not that that how do I not that do I start from the top?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, we start from the top fire burns from top to bottom everyone knows this
What am I doing? Gosh, so dark, I'm like legally blind. I got a lit up
Don't worry guys. I'm gonna leave. Okay. Okay. This is further freaking place Bing bong Bing. Oh,
No, not your pretty place it looks so good
I'm burning I am burning I am on fire. I am on fire with this house. It hurts. How God does it hurt Oh
God all right, I bet about
Oh
God oh god, you're good. Y'all get back up. Oh god. I'm almost dead
It's fine fine gamer gaming week ok gamers time to bounce. Oh, that's what I like to see
Smash like if that was epic. Alright, I think this one takes us back home actually
Slant Jernigan it was epic. Not you it was very epic. Here you go eat
Alright gamers
Spend jurgen, please look away because I have something that I have to do
And I don't really I've been trading to do this I'm gonna have to
It has to be done
Okay, suddenly. I feel like sleeping crazy. Oh my god. What are you doing here? What are you selling?
Garbage, you're selling garbage slime balls. It's okay. I'll take it. I'll take a slime ball. I'll take a sign ball. Oh
Don't don't mind me. Yes. I know. I'm rich it's whatever
Just because you're poor like don't feel bad. It's all about the storms. All right. Give me the slime ball
Give me the slime ball. Give it a slime ball. I asked you for one thing
Slime boy, please
Can I level up this guy? No, you can't
What for for one slime ball?
Get out of the way. I spit on you. Oh god
He took my money took my money took my money for for one slime ball. Get the freak out of my house
How dare you say? What do you stand?
Daddy I
Will kill you too
Technically you're not responsible, but I will do it
But I don't want to kill in front of your again your your kind your cousins, whatever you are. Okay?
Slime ball my slime ball and stupid slime ball and dummy
Dum-dum you spent you if you saw what I just saw you'd be so angry
So I'm not even gonna tell you what just happened. So the reason why I murdered all these sheeps
Is because
Apparently you can dye the sheep. And then that way you don't have to please people playing if you know what I mean
But there's a bunch of freaking. All right lamps. I'm really sorry about that. I hope we can still work together
Gosh, why are they all still here do I physically have no one? I need to separate them and I have no one I
Must have someone I have known that I knew I had one
God, damn, I'm a gamer. This is how you know, I'm a gamer. Get out of my sight
How dare you stick with him guy? Alright, I'll deal with you in a second
Alright, I need y'all to come over here. Y'all come over here. That's right. Dummy dump your bunch of dummy thumbs
You know that being bond being bomb
Goddamn locked in now gosh, dammit. I need carpet AAS a freakin peepee
All right we go birthday
Get out of my way. I hate cheap
Okay. All right shape come here dummy dumps
You're a bunch of dummy thumbs you fell for the oldest trick in the book
All this trick in the book and you fell for it
Dummy thumbs spend what are you doing here? Don't talk to these guys
Don't talk to these guys. I don't want you near them
And we'll do another section here perfect
Okay, if I get this right I can die. I can buy them. Oh
my freaking licky licky
That's all so so now when they freak they'll make white
Yellow babies question mark yes. All right, you guys be blue?
Okay, all right awesome, I like this and then I want red, okay look so crazy
African I'll do more blue I like the way All Right today gamers eat
Thanks to sheep
Dumb me thumbs Spanish. I told you not to talk to these guys, please. Okay, you guys will be black shell and
Oh, no, I ran out of dye. Which means you die
Okay, I treat you. Well, I treat you all well, but you have to behave. Oh, no ran out oopsie oopsie oopsie
Sorry, I'm so sorry get it. Let's get out of here. Let's get out of this ditch these creeps. Can you guys freak off Oh
Both Gallo is back gamers don't care is back both couch back now. Get out. Get out. I don't want to kill a llama
Oh, that's so weird. The llamas just disappeared Hey, are you guys making out Jesus Sven?
Spent you're not God
Okay, it's fine it's fine
What was I doing? Oh, yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. I got it. I got it. I got it. So now we can finally
We can fin element there as we say in this fandom
Complete the IKEA Tower in its glorious form the way. It's meant to be. All right, shake a sheep
chop chop chop chop chop, let me show and
Hey
I want to I want nothing. I want nothing to do with you. You're garbage. You're trash. You're all trash. Give me nothing to me
At least you're not. Yep. Think about that. I lose you're not yet. Oh my god. You guys go fast. You're all right
Stop growing stop. I said stop. Okay. So now we complete IKEA Tower. How should we do it?
Why?
Oh my god, IKEA Tower is so beautiful. I'm teary-eyed
I never thought a monument would have such impact and meaning for me
But it's truly a sight to see if you guys ever pass by in my area in my minecraft server
You gotta come check out the IKEA Tower. I'm telling you
Let's sing never on you
Oh
Right, I forgot to show you guys. I got a swimming pool. It's pretty epic. Look I got trampoline as well
okay, and
The best part it's pot. It's it's lava powered
Yeah
I'm actually 12
Okay, I know you're impressed Stuart lava powered cutting-edge technology only minecraft veterans would understand
Oh my god. It's beautiful
glory to the IKEA tower it will guide me in the darkest hour to my way back home to uragan and
Spend the force sent please
We talked about this you cannot talk
He still loves me guys, he still loves me he chooses not to look at me for a fervor purpose
Alright just sitting there, please. I can only want one boat cow and one only where did my boat go? All right
Well fine just as long as boat cows things. I don't really care what he does
It's been half the time in this game. Just categorizing my items
The gamers will understand I don't know if this is a good idea but I have this man
that goes to an
Ocean Explorer and I'm like that's pretty epic. I kind of want to check it out
So we're just gonna do that gamers because that's what minecraft is all about. Okay, so let's check out this map Sven
This looks like it's pretty
freaky deaky far away
We might have to bring we might have to bring how do I know how far away that is hold it in one hand
Yeah, we're a tiny little dot aren't we son?
So then you're gonna have to hold down the fort I'm gonna check out through the portal first
Alright, so let's look at the map. Okay. Looks like we're getting closer
So we have to head north or west
Okay gamers. Let's go the now that might nether sucks
Everyone keeps saying I find I'm really lucky in this game, but I find a lot of stuff
But my nether saw got its it is not good don't like it. There's nothing there's nothing here. Help me find stuff gamers
Come on, how North cannot be talking here in gamers. Oh, I have a gamer question
If I didn't makes men sit down and I go that no he wouldn't teleport but further than the nether port
No, that would be impossible. I have so many questions
Looks like we went to look for gamers
And back it go Houston. Yeah. All right. Let's try this portal. I
Think this is from where I got the mat to begin with and we gotta go
Okay, fine this this'll do it'll do as we say in Sweden. Did it do it?
Will you ever restock gosh freaky? All right, so he's the one that saw me there man
Okay, we gotta go
North north to my horse. God, I wish you're against murugan was here. Should we go should we just get uragan?
I think it'll be quicker. Anyway. Oh, yeah, you guys told me I don't know if this is true
But if the underneath the Bell, you should dig it at you. Ah
My paper my paper. It's gonna get wet can't see anything. Hello
Are you guys lying to me you're lying to me again can it see this is what happens when you break tress
Oh
Wow, that was so cool guys. Thanks for the tip. Really appreciate it
Apparently I'm supposed to be able to fit Jurgen in the boat, which seems crazy
How
How does he fit in boat Jurgen get in the boat? Jörgen get in the boat?
Whoa, so if I drop the lasso, I still have it
That makes no sense. Oh, I had two of them
We got a head outspend my man, I'm sorry, but last time you nearly drowned and I'm not putting that through again
Let's go you're gone
Hey, look, it's your uncle here again
Maybe one day I altai my uncle see this is what I like. Me and Jurgen own adventures just
Like having a bro time isn't that right killing she wait can the water temple be on land No
Misaka in flaw scible
Wait what Nunnally the freaky deaky picky? Okay. So before we head out, I'm gonna have to dig up some sand
For our sand temple now who would bring their horse to a water temple, you might ask a
Man that loves his horse. Don't judge right Jurgen. Normally I would leave you there, but I don't try. I just don't trust you
God I don't like this it's so far away, you know, is that it?
Okay, your again we set up base here Oh freak it's so deep Oh God, ah
Comfort Jurgen, you can swim right? It's fine, right? Oh, yeah. I have knocked back on my sword. They fly back so hard
Stake
All right, cool so it's dark as well that's excellent I can already not see underwater
I know you can use like a potion to make you see underwater and stuff, but that's for lamer gamers
And I'm not a lame regular. I'm just a gamer. So I think if you put a door, oh god, it's not gonna work
What am I doing?
Okay
I
Literally can't even see it anymore. Did I bring my acquaintance your helmet? No, I didn't I forgot it. Ah gosh
alright
Wait is over there it's north. Oh it is there I don't think that's it
What what is this
Yeah, what would it say? Whoa, it's so cool
Dye it shouting mate. Oh
My god is shouting me
What is that oh
My god, alright, let's go to the top first I
Got what is these laser looking son of a guns? Don't know don't shoot a gamer
I'll block it
Was that it thought oh you got
All right think this is the entrance
All right, so now we just placed it
What the Frick is that? Oh
It's a fence Frick. I put on the wrong thing
Okay, so I can breathe in the doors
See this
I'm actually so nervous
Okay, all right keep our head cool let's think about who with love and who we were doing this for
I wish I brought more doors. I put down the fence. I'm supposed to put down the gate
Let me try this. Just okay
Yeah, I wish I brought an axe
Way, I physically can't break it down
What about the gate? Can I break down the game? Oh wait, I have the mining sickness thing. Right? Is that what it is?
We're gonna do shoot with laser. Oh
I didn't mean that
Oh, thank you, that's good man. This is making me anxious. Oh, okay
Doors are off. I freaked up here again. I freaked up
Your again, you light up my world now wait cabaret music. Let's not fuck with it
God I just have to rain and be so epic all the time. I
Just have one normal chill episode. Where's my boat? There? You are set a freaking wizard desert. Oh, yeah, it's gaming time
Oh god, oh god is fat
This is really bad, oh god, I'm crazy
That was a really bad idea. Oh
You're again Oh God shoo
Let's not do that, I'll do that. Ah, yes the tower
The tower of Ikea guys the way
Doors
They spent doors
Lots of doors unless you're a door don't talk to me anymore
Rain again. It's the desert. Come on knotch, but I don't work on game anymore fit not
This makes no sense. So I just realized something the map hasn't been filled in
Oh, it has a low bang
I think the water temple we found is a different one because it doesn't match the map, right? Juergen Perkins Morgan. I
Would have set up a camp there
Okay
Bing bong Bing Oh
All right, we are officially in 42 doors let's do this get away get away shoosh
Okay 42
Okay, all right we've been in here
Another door
Let's place a door in each room. All right, it looks like I already did thank you. I
Swear, I've been in here what there's nowhere to go. Are you kidding me? Oh
I can go up here. Whoa. Oh my gosh. I'm gonna get lost. Okay
Don't worry. I'll remember just follow the door sir, Omaha. This makes absolutely no sense. By the way. I
Bet everyone else that did this just like
Prepared properly. I'm just like doors. I'll bring doors. Oh, you can go down there. Uh-huh. All right
What about here? There's something here gamers
Nothing door
door door
All right, so wait that means we got to go down here
Hey, dude, I'm a door
All right, I'm a dude
Where do you go? Okay. Oh, there is Oh God Frick. This place is huge
Alright, alright, let's go back. There's nothing here. I'm trying to remember the layout so that when it all comes down I
Will not freak up. Oh gosh. It's dark in here. Alright, so nothing up here down here
No, nothing. What am I doing? Nothing here either what the freaky god? I'm so anxious. This is so stressful
If I die uragan
Alright, that's a bit more than I bargained
Eat ass. Oh
Wait, oh I take damage. Hey
I'm just a guy in with a thorn
Okay, we can go up here again 36 more doors it's fine plenty of doors got plenty of doors
Wait, where am I? Oh god door the door
Huck I'm stuck. I'm stuck Thor Thor I need the door AAS a freaking PP. Oh
If they bubble down
They die epic. I
Think I'm supposed to go up here
freak away you little
PPP
Come on
Now I've been here
So I think
The pressure is in that thing
And if I just drink this boat cow milk the potion disappears and I can just mine my way through. Oh
We found it door
Door here dammit. We got the thing again
LARP
Give me that gold
Yes, oh god, I need to Nicole Nicole Nicole
Give me the gold Oh
Todd thorne. Oh god Thor I
Breathing you're gonna be okay. That's perfect. I can nearly stand here. Okay. Oh
We got over the gold we got a little yes, yes, yes. Yes. Yes assistance
Plan for this gamer to bounce
From wherever you came from which I don't really remember yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes
Lay oh god, let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Yeah
Yeah, I got
Gotta get back. I
Got the gold yard again, I got the gone
Ha ha ha ha cheese my way through it baby. Oh
My god, that was stressful
Let's head back home here again. You're very good. Boy. You're again Oh God, we're sinking you're again
You're gonna stop dancing
Jurgen this is not a dancing contest
You can't do the stanky leg yard. Can we talked about this many times?
Okay, it makes me uncomfortable that you're walking on two legs. Can you stop please?
This is what happens when you teach your pets the stanky leg
She's never looked as beautiful
Look at that symbol of trust and hope again
We're back homes that it was epic, I believe I got a drink somewhere more of that delicious. I
Don't mind if I do. Thank you
Don't judge me
Now what am I gonna do with that gold? You might ask Sven. Well, it's for an old friend
Alright guys, that's it for this week's episode white what?
Smash like for another one and I see you and spend tomorrow buy
What you never played super simulator
You know, it's fun right I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay. I'll cut you a deal
The game is available for free and that's a great price